now your career really started on comedy
central right with the the man show
uh crank anchors all that was all on
comedy central
and i'm dying to ask you with dave
chappelle being in the news
saying with this boycott dave chappelle
he's outraged that he's not being paid
for
for the the chappelle show on netflix
he was more mad about it being on hbo
yeah but uh i'm
just i'm interested in your take on that
like uh it seems that it says don't
watch that show unless they pay me
but then i can't help but think didn't
he just get
like a full 20 to 20 million dollars
for each and every special like he's
like a three special deal for 60 million
like like uh is it
is it wrong to have trouble taking that
seriously
that uh he demands to be paid for for
the show that
that represented him paying his dues
early in his career
and if not if not should i say people
should boycott jackass shows because i
didn't get paid
[ __ ] yeah you know i think there's
two thought process processes and uh
and they're probably both right in their
own way like on one hand you go
well the guy did five specials on
netflix and he made 100 million bucks so
what are you complaining about or comedy
central paid you when you did the
chappelle
show and you made tons of dough so what
are you complaining about you go
all right that's that's a sensible
argument and then the other
argument is well but if other people are
profiting
off of something you created and they're
getting rich off it then why are they
getting rich off it and not letting you
wet your beak
and they're both they're both arguments
they're both sort of sensible arguments
you know either way
um and and i i guess both arguments are
right
um either way all entities here
are doing you know whether it's netflix
or comedy central or hbo or dave
chappelle
they're all doing exceedingly well so we
shouldn't give a [ __ ] about
either one
yeah dude